he's Michael Vick Fox Sports NFL analyst
former number one overall pick and that
2001 draft and you can catch him on Fox
NFL kickoff Sunday starting at 11:00
a.m. Eastern Michael Vick joins us on
the program Michael thanks for joining
us there's so many people want to
compare you to Lamar Jackson or vice
versa but what do you think Lamar does
differently than you did so here the
certain level of poise I think it's very
early early in this career right now I
was in sharing the poise and my second
year the your modern the magis makes you
look different I don't know I don't know
and you know I always just go to the
very back to the altercations and I
think that's a strength extremely
important to performances you know and
we Sunday I would say more so you know
the all fencing just of positioning he's
been pretend as making very successful
we can't really count but it also feels
like that we embrace this style Mike and
I wondered how much pressure you got to
stay in the pocket when you were playing
as opposed to what Lamar and Kyla Murray
are doing now yeah well it was personal
preference for me to stay in the pocket
to try to move the chains you know with
my arm just as much as I deal with my
legs and when it all came together I
felt you know as if I was doing
something that was kind of expediting
the process so to speak and you know it
was fast paced and it was fun you know
especially when I was young so it's it's
great to see you know because of the
pressure that I started to feel and I
put on myself as far as being in the
pocket there you know that pressure is
not there for these guys right now and
it's joyner this style of play can exist
and I feel what do you remember about
that season that you rushed for a
thousand yards first of all I remember
staying healthy the entire year not
having any injuries and just being you
know accountable every Sunday
I had a burden on me sometimes being
injury prone you know kinda stigma at
time and you know I started to believe
in and when I started to believe those
things happen but that year was just
about chasing the record you know trying
to you know be the first to ever do it
even though the the guys before me was
great and what they did and then mobile
and what they represented and and I just
wanted that I wanted to do something
different in history book so I just
remember just chasing the goal and at
the same time is trying to win as many
days as I could
yeah I'm wondering what you could have
rushed for I mean we had we had the
office to rush for more it's just those
plays wasn't called enough but it was a
part of our office that we we used with
all the defenses and the opposition so
yeah it certainly could have been more I
feel like but the coaches didn't want to
put me in harm's way I guess or whatever
their thinking was we didn't maximize it
the way we said if the 49ers ask for any
tips on what to do with Lamar Jackson
what advice would you give the 49ers
with this game coming up this weekend I
don't know nothin what the Rams Bengals
and the Texas try because it's not going
to work and you know those guys are
coming right at you coming down here
they come out and hit you with the brine
gang and it's not gonna mouth and I
don't think enough credit is given to
the offensive linemen right now but it
will be in due time but you know just
shudder you know create some type of
defense that you know I think equates to
some form of containment that's all I
can see and it's so hard because they're
coming at you with a package you know
not just the representative showing you
the same thing every time you know it's
always a different look you know it's
always a different wrinkle each and
every week and what I've seen last week
off and then look the same
they've built another pack
it's that created you know so much
concern for the Los Angeles Rams and
starting from the beginning of the game
he's Michael Vick Fox Sports NFL analyst
you can see him on Fox NFL kickoff
Sundays at 11 a.m. Eastern this weekend
you know avoiding a big hit when when
you're a quarterback who runs or keeps
the play alive Russell Wilson's
unbelievable at doing this
rg3 was horrible at doing this and then
you got Kyler and now you got Lamar what
what is what is it what would be your
strategy of trying to avoid a big hit if
you're a mobile quarterback when your
mobile is extremely hard to sometimes do
not be able to slow down and you can't
slow down
all right you plan on such a fast pace
of running you know at top speed you
know it's difficult to get down it's
difficult to get your feet in a position
where you can slide and that's why we
sometimes take the big hitters guys like
you know Callum area and Russell Wilson
who we're not moving as fast we're
moving fast enough to where they're
under control and so I think there will
be times that you will see Lamar slide
but I don't think it's gonna happen in
the near future
he's hitting the edges and he's attack
in the middle with extreme speed and you
know it's gonna make it difficult em to
get down but the other guys who are like
I said I'm not moving you know as fast I
have a better chance of protecting
themselves based on body position feels
like it feels like these coaches James
offensive coordinators are opening their
eyes a little bit more Mike to the
success you have in college with these
players and I I applaud the Ravens and I
applaud the Carolina Panthers you bring
in Cam you bring in Lamar but you bring
in their offense so I want you to be
comfortable in in your own offense
because it's tough enough to play that
position do you see this as a trend here
with you know some of these quarterbacks
who are successful in college we're just
not sure if they can make
transition to being successful in the
pros yeah I think so and when you look
at Arizona's offense and what they're
doing you know cooking brain they plan
the same same type of offense that
calimary ran when he was at Oklahoma and
what that does is it's a lot it allows
you to give these guys and just
instantly started teaching off the
things that they know what they do well
and then you can add more to the offense
which gives you more time to concentrate
on what your quarterback really needs to
be a success and show that he can be
comfortable and he can claim early as a
rookie and you can have a guy that can
step in and not feel like he's been
thrown into the fire and I feel like and
I feel like he's just you know in the
you know the mineral book you know a
difficult situation and they can get
very sticky you know if you lose
confidence so confidence is key and I
think these coaches are saying look you
know we've got what are we gonna do
we're gonna put this guy in a position
where he can go succeed early have
confidence and not feel like you gotta
do everything it makes it easier if I
put you at 23 years of age I got Lamar
and I got Kyler Murray and we're lined
up for a 40 I'm gonna give them a good
run well you're not gonna win yeah
straight-line 40-yard dash I mean I was
the best friend and the Jim's like I ran
forward so when I don't know too many
people around for to is consistently but
I did it a couple of times you know I
would have been very difficult to beat
enumeration of 23
what about Deion was too young faster
than you or just maybe quicker yeah davi
o'clock there you might have collectin
is no fool
maybe in the 4-1 if I'm not mistaken
yeah so be honest probably greatest
athlete of all time for sure really
I'm an I don't know
certainly for so certainly the practice
I can't be enough bill you think he's
the fastest player he's ever played in
the NFL he faster than Bo Jackson Joey
Galloway I mean yeah I mean for said
Deion Sanders running for one I don't
know if you heard what I heard and I
don't know if there's any truth behind
it with Mike I think beyond my age the
room with a spring I think Deion is the
one who spread the rumor that he can run
I know Joey Galloway and Darryl Greene
could go
seems like so many species that has come
through the NFL that I'm just in the
line of long lineage of guys who were
superior as the league's Manning and his
generation always produces five or six
guys that you can always compare to one
another and say you know I wonder what
that racism would have looked like you
know every beginner and modern time
that'd be fun no but like amazing I'd
probably take Deion I'd take Deion over
anybody yeah I'm taking prime time man
he's back in the day and the fact that
you know he was uh when the defensive
side of the ball made it you know even
more difficult for offenses to you know
get away from especially when he got the
good things cowboys 49ers ahead is
because the line in front of it he was
really able to try hey Mike have a great
Thanksgiving always great to catch up
with you and thanks we appreciate your
time as always
all right that's Mike Vick sports Fox
Sports NFL analyst and you can see him
on Fox NFL kickoff Sundays at 11:00 a.m.
Eastern for more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]